vampires et lycans sont en guerre depuis
des siècles transformant notre monde en
champ de bataille
pour moi c'est une affaire personnelle
tout ce que j'ai aimé ont été
pourchassés aujourd'hui une nouvelle
guerre est menée c'est le nain les
lycans reviennent à la charge
ils ont à nouveau chef mario j'en ai
fini avec cette guerre elle n'en a pas
fini avec toi
ils veulent qu'on s'en est celui de ta
fille même moi je ne sais pas où est tu
vas aller porter un message dit attends
marius que j'arrive
c'est assez clair que message
nous avons besoin de selene pour mettre
fin à cette guerre on ne peut pas lui
faire confiance
elle est la plus pure de nos tous c'est
sûr elle ira pause l'avenir des lycans
et des vampires
quand nous aurons le sens de sa laine et
de sa fille nous deviendrons avancé
blanc je deviendrai plus puissante que
n'importe quel vampire de cette
assemblée
vous devez midi à la partie j'ai va dans
le nord là bas tu trouveras des réponses
si tu veux gagner cette guerre il faudra
te transformer pour aller plus loin
l'avocat guerriers de tarnos mais ne
sait encore aventuré
impossible
plus rien ne peut l'arrêter
sont beaucoup trop de morts j'ai l'air
d'être inquiète
tout ce que je veux c'est ton sang
vient le chercher